[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i don't like salmon cooked am i weird i
like i like raw salmonella give it to me
oh baby i might get wrong i wanted to
roll a summit with a choppy skin
what if we flew one over and just said
just kidding just get yeah just kidding
just kidding this one exploded into just
yeah like [ __ ] rainbow you know like
smoke it was like psych it bubbles it's
bubble spells we dropped a nuke of
bubbles
so crazy that's the type of [ __ ] body
needs to do if he wants to get my vote
by the way you're we're on the set of
whiskey ginger andrew centino and i have
started our new show called good friends
good friends good friends speaking of
which last night me and this good friend
uh we did a show together in hollywood
yeah we did two shows g-o-o-d friend and
then bobby's g-o-o
you fill in the blank
so i'm like just give me the johnson
johnson i gotta get out there and start
eating [ __ ]
[Laughter]
imagine i just did full diced clay oh
i just got the vaccine
so i can eat your ass now
the nice guy cometh high [ __ ] hide
this a little bit look at this now push
it down it's in your face i want to see
how beautiful your face is [ __ ] girl
yeah yeah yeah
yeah blackhawk pushing a second because
it's covering up your pretty face
that's the one you broke oh yeah see you
broke you're never gonna be able to turn
that all right well
[Music]
there you go i cause you know we had the
mail in voting you know like in new york
as i'm sure you guys did here and then
white mail in voting by the way white
male in voting so jasmine my puerto
rican uh baby mama girlfriend esposa she
asked me to drop her vote off in the you
know elector in the ballot box and i was
waiting on a long line and i noticed she
didn't uh seal it so i took a peek and i
saw us for joey b tore it up do it in
the tear it up tear it up
trashthevax.com
go check it out
[Laughter]
she was like that's a felony i said i'll
call ice right now
and [ __ ] t-o-t now we fight back to
the island kid yeah there was a few
articles published a long time ago that
said there's andrew santino gay and then
who's my lover and they were searching
for who my male lovers were who was and
my dad found out and he was like what is
this you're gay online stuff what is
this i'm like don't worry about it i
know dude it says i'm gay there too but
what can you do no i'm the one that put
it out there yeah i like leaking it i
like it i have a goal i want to get on
wiki feet i want to get my puppy you got
your puppies on weekly feed i'm on my
weekend wow pull it up but i want to see
how much i am now because i think it
changes what was your original reiki
feet
it you know uh the guy from h3 ethan
showed it to me i like that katie oh no
no not wiki feet with the men one is
different oh oh you oh i can't i can't
get men's feet on no wiki feet for men
is called something else and i'm stupid
but it's it's called that's stupid
andrew wiki what is it it's not wiki
feet men let me see andrew santino i was
on there right because i got cutesy
pootsies oh i am you do i am on there
what's it called um it's just it no it's
literally men wiki feet men weak doubt
four point nine out of five four point
nine one out of five yummy some of these
images are hot hot hot
let's see
4.9 out of five on men wiki feet and i
got to tell you you know why because i
take good care of my feet you do
you wash them i clip my nails nothing is
more repulsive to me when guys have
nasty toenails oh i'm on a tail what do
you got papa uh buddy i got a 3.21 out
of
five do you think from the day adam
silver was born he's looked like he was
dying of cancer
he's that man does look like he's dying
of cancer for the last 30 years i mean
he doesn't even have eyebrows he was
born bald yeah you know that he never
grew hair he never wants crew he
actually never grew hair never grew hair
he looks like a slip like he just like
he seems like he he's probably the best
commissioner
he looks slippery he's going to get away
he looks like a slippery
tag you're never going to get him he's a
slippery little [ __ ] hide and go seek
he'll get away because he could go under
door crests i mean he's gone on my
podcast christy chaos we last week we
interviewed um my girlfriend's
transgender uncle
man did i love it because man that i
love tt jerry literally dude he this mic
by his mouth he just because at first i
thought he was joking i'm like oh he
just wants to suck it i was like oh this
guy's good for the camera but then he
told us he texted jasmine was like she
he had to call his like old lover
because he just was in the mood for
black [ __ ] because of these because of
these he was it's like it's like craig
he just love he craves [ __ ] more than
anyone i've ever met so shout out to tt
shout out i love you i love the
interview i love also he could i the
story i love the most was that he
couldn't catch the d in the showers
because he was dropping this open people
were annoyed he kept dropping the self
they were annoyed yet but he and and
then and then if you got too close to
him and you because there was a guy who
just used to put his penis in the cell
and be like suck this and he said he was
just starting to piss him off he said he
started to get offended by it and he
said the guy just would leave his dick
limp over the prison thing so he said
one day he uh he folded up a can of tuna
fish he took the little cannon two fish
so he sliced his dick off
i swear to god dude and he told us crazy
stories he came into my apartment
because we do the show for my apartment
he came into my apartment wearing one of
my sweatshirts from the denver comedy
works because i just will give back like
you know a lot of people drop bags off
to the salvation army yeah i dropped
them off to my girlfriend's puerto rican
family that's like i just give them my
clothes and every time at an event
they're wearing something of mine so he
literally came into my house
with the denver comedy work sweatshirt
and left with one of jasmine's jackets
so he walked in with my clothes and left
with hers because he's [ __ ] crazy
seriously like i'm not going to be one
of those guys like who could hear that
way cause it's stupid la la is a great
city yeah but the the covet hysteria
here is a little scary
although it's a little scary you know
what today is
hitler's birthday yes it is
[Laughter]
your daughter doesn't really like me she
she likes the idea of me as your daddy's
friend yeah but she's scared because i'm
a ginge how about this but then outside
of the car she waved to me and she said
will you come in our car and drive with
us yeah so maybe she did say that and
when we got home that night when we hung
out the other night she asked jasmine
vinnie we call her in the show she asked
her if the baby inside her belly was
yours and i said i hope so well i
genuinely hope so because i don't have
to deal with another child support
payment okay look at it like this let's
say the kid comes out and it's not your
kid okay let's say it's somebody else's
not mine because i don't want to even go
there because it could have been a
possibility at some point because jazz
and i did meet once in harlem i believe
it that being said if it's somebody
else's kid
what's your move seriously you find out
being dead serious what's that honest
reaction she comes to you the baby comes
out
it's not yours it's yeah and it's
obvious it's a little tan got a lot of
pigment in that skin got a lot of
pigment
in it looks like bobby lee a little bit
no i'm saying a lot of melanin melon
looks like it could be an athlete oh god
definitely not yours looks like a
democrat
okay like a demo yeah uh what do you do
if you're like that's not my baby i
to be honest with you if you told me
right now my daughter wasn't mine you
know uh paternally yeah i it wouldn't
bother it would i wouldn't change a
thing that's because you've raised her
at this point if a baby comes out new
and you know it's not yours in the
hospital what do you do then then i
would say i would probably
what would i do i
you're not gonna
i don't know if i hit her the baby i
mean oh the baby yeah
yeah
well it depends it depends if it's a boy
or if it's a girl yeah that's true if it
was a boy i think i'd stay around
if it was your girl i'd say you're going
to china
[Laughter]
can i come over to your house with my
family yes please seriously yeah we're
gonna do the wife swap i know we are we
already mine was six months pregnant my
wife's six months ago what did your wife
say about the wife swap day she said
totally cool she said that she because
you have red hair she said she wants to
go to clear with her doctor first yeah
we're not sure with redheads with
pregnancy and i understand you know what
she said with everything's been going on
and you know she does it in her culture
at that satan in diablo she doesn't want
to go near it so but her doctor cleared
and said that you're fully good to go
you're fine in the ass you can't go in
her puss clearly yeah that's it dude
what if i get her pregnant through the
ass anyway just because they're so
fertile flea fertile myrtle those
i can't eat all that tortilla what'd
your wife eat
she finished what i didn't eat and then
ate two other burritos because she's a
chubber
[Laughter]
yo um well yeah i know i don't let it
reap by the way i don't let her eat
before noon yeah you can't
no you don't get to eat before no i know
dude my you got to see i posted a
picture of my girl's belly the other day
looking gloated she's looking good yeah
but she's [ __ ] you see her are you
seeing the baby kick
oh yeah because i keep forgetting i have
a baby in there there's a baby in there
there's a baby in there because i was
like hey you gotta [ __ ] chill on the
pepsis but there's a bambino let me ask
you this you get lazy you ever [ __ ]
mitzi shore
me yeah
yeah that's a yes
[Laughter]
you know what she dated a lot of comics
she did well it wasn't rest in peace
mitts oh she passed away she died
oh you didn't go you had sex with a
corpse you know doing the show on the
round i was just a little bit like
it was weird logan paul was in the front
row oh yeah
he was there youtube lp was there lp was
he was there with his buddies and his
crew and his clique and uh
he he applauded he was very nice very
polite i said hello to him i met him
after the show i never met him before
great kid nice kid
multi-multi-multi-multi-multi-multi-millionaire
millionaire i looked up online what he
was selling pokemon cards for those are
that ftp stuff or whatever yeah he made
three and a half trillion in one day oh
yeah nft he gave um he gave my you know
because we went to ftp well i'm a dad
i'm a dad you're selling hivs pokemons
yeah what are you doing
i did uh i went and exercised at his
house uh a couple of days ago and i
brought my stepson and he gave my one of
his friends gave my stepson a freaking
mint edition pokemon card does does your
stepson know who he is yes he's old
enough to be in he does but you know
what was cool about my stepson he knew
who he was but he didn't fanboy at all
he was like well it wasn't until we got
back in the car and leaving i was like
you know what that is he was like yeah
it's logan paul i'm like you didn't
freak out he was like he's just on
youtube i was like so
that kid is so cool cool cool he's just
on youtube because he's just on youtube
i was like yeah but you see like how
cool this house was or whatever and then
my steps was like my dad has a bigger
house than that i was like no he doesn't
no he doesn't he lives in a studio in
long island he lives in the basement of
a chinese restaurant inventing her skin
little different
what's the oldest woman you would
consider having sex with
how old what's two like what's the age
limit the honored you have sex with 100
year old woman no that's the eight
that's the limit 99 is my tip top yeah
yeah 99 is probably the highest i go
what's my limit i don't know nothing up
what do you mean i mean if they're down
if if if later in life
you know the old bag passes away and i'm
a single mingle and i'm 76 and you know
an 86 year old comes up and you're gonna
hit that she's feeling it yeah i just
you don't want to break her hip you just
got to be careful you know what
something that's that's really going to
hold if we live this long what's really
going to what just sucks to be a man
because my father tells me this he said
your mind like you still look at a 25
year old gorgeous girl playing
volleyball and want to be like i want to
have sex with her he said that doesn't
go away in your mind ever as a guy right
so he said men who are like 85 years old
in wheelchairs that are [ __ ] their
pants cornballs still want to try to
jerk off to the hot nurse that's why
they do that's why they always ask the
nurse they're like would you mind
tugging on my ding-dong and the nurse is
like come on mr d you know i can't do
that yeah they and they have to play
along with these goals just do it i
think so like if they really can't some
of them spit and look away you know a
little bit that will get you your pills
yeah because
at that point you're not you're not you
don't have any you know why should nurse
uh nursing homes and all that stuff they
should be giving out sex toys by the way
sex toy companies if you're listening
you should support them every guy should
get a fleshlight in the sex in the sex
good idea and everybody everybody in a
nurse home every man in this room should
be legally allowed to get a prostitute
or get a happy ending massage if they
want they want to go deshawn watts and
they go daishon they should be able to
deshine
it's actually is it deshaun or deshawn
does it really matter well to somebody
we know it does
i was jogging the other day like with no
mask on which is like okay in new york
cause you're not around people i jog
with no mess because i'm in my
neighborhood right i'm near nobody
you're near nobody yeah and i'm like and
i'm just like you know
people look at you and with this stink
eye and i'm like listen dude what do you
want me to do dude that's what i said
listen dude because it gets to the point
where it's like okay listen i want to be
i want to just walk up to somebody be
like look trump lost okay you don't have
to [ __ ] you don't have to
you know make this a political issue
with the mask anymore you won you won
your [ __ ] guy won yeah so you don't
have to that you could take the mask off
now you weigh zhongzhang
i didn't say it i didn't say it you got
a [ __ ] coin baby i'm the bitcoin baby
you got one bit i got a few i'm not even
gonna tell you about it really i'm
invested i'm deep i'm i'm sunk how many
biddies when's the first time you bought
a bitcoin got a couple of bitcoins about
a year ago okay so you got real big so
you got money in there can i tell you
something i have no bitcoins what i want
it so bad i don't know how to do it i
don't even know how to do it i don't
know where to go coinbase baby you got
to download the coinbase app or gemini i
went in i'm so scared who's got the
money where does it go who's is it i see
i don't think for me i'm kind of just
like whatever it is it is i went in
there i got a bitcoin i just bought one
i'm holding on to it and it's it's up
dude you got one whole coin i got one
whole coin and i got three ethereums and
then i got an ethereum it sounds like
witchcraft this this is this sounds like
uh uh dungeons and dragons see in a
theater i have two ethereum so you're
one bitcoin and i'll see you as good
odium
it sounds so dork [ __ ] i can't i don't
know what to do i know people like is it
an actual coin and i'm like dude i don't
know man they should mail you a coin
yeah my dad was like i don't unders he's
like do you understand it i was like not
really he was like how much did you
invest i was like 60k
did so much six i was like 60k dad [ __ ]
it i'm chrissy bitcoins
like super mario getting the coins
then i go down the tunnel
now but you know what if the bottom all
falls out well then you know that's the
thing is my girl and my kids were like
oh we're going to have a house and i was
like no we're not we went to crypto so
we're gonna stay in the [ __ ] two
floor walk up in bay ridge
[Music]
[Music]
brooklyn big
[Music]
my
[Music]